are we happy with Joe Budden oh yeah
absolutely no I mean let me hold on let
me show you this picture of him I do
this other one I mean like this action
he's taking right now sending troops
down to the Border should we be like
that's a good thing please do it more I
think it's a start yeah but that's it
it's just a start it's something that
should have happened right as he got in
office he shouldn't have repealed any of
the immigration plans that Trump had
because they were working and now that
he's doing that he's got a back pedal
because even normal Americans are
starting to see okay this is kind of
weird that we're allowing anybody and
everybody through so I think this is
their way of almost compensating right
before election seizing saying hey we
understand your problems conservatives
not you Maga terrorists though because
we don't like you guys but General
conservatives and progressives we know
you want to secure border so this is our
way of giving it to you I think it's
just to buy election points do you
remember his first state of the union
address where he just started
appropriating Trump's talking points he
did said that we need to secure the
Border I mean when your agenda
capitalism these are capitalism we're
good man defend the police don't defend
him